this is where we left off in the
previous video A and B happening
together is written as a inverted u b or
a intersection B an event a or event b
or both happening together is written as
Au u b or a union B let's look at a very
simple example to understand this
consider the set of first 10 natural
numbers from 1 to 10 now consider two
events let a be the event of getting an
even number and let B be an event of
getting a number greater than five let's
analyze the two events even numbers are
multiples of two there are five even
numbers in this set 2 4 6 8 and 10 let's
write it next to a 2 4 6 8 and 10 and
and there are five numbers that are
greater than five 6 7 8 9 and 10 so next
to B let's write 6 7 8 9 and 10 first
let's look at a intersection B it is the
case of both events occurring together
the number in this set should be even
and should be greater than five
basically it will be the set of numbers
that are common to both these sets we
can see that six is common to both 8 and
10 are also common to both so it will be
6 8 and 10 three
numbers you can see that each of them
are greater than five and are even two
so what will be the probability of
events A and B happening together three
numbers out of a possible 10 so the
probability of both events A and B
happening together will be 3x 10
this also equals 0.3 or
30% in layman terms we can say that
there is a 30% chance of picking up a
number that is even and greater than
five let's zoom out and see what a union
B will be equal to this is interesting
it means either getting an even number
or a number greater than five or a
number which is both even and greater
than five so let us note the even
numbers first 2 4 6 8 and 10 are the
even numbers we also need to jot down
numbers greater than five 6 is greater
than 5 but it's already included in the
even numbers list so we don't write it
down remember numbers should not be
repeated the next number greater than
five is seven and that is not written so
we write a seven similarly 8 and 10 are
already included what remains is nine so
these are the possibilities of event A
or B happening seven in all no matter
what number we pick from the set it will
surely be either even or greater than
five or it is possible that our pick is
both even and greater than
five what we are interested in is
probability of A or B there are seven
numbers here out of a possible 10 so the
probability of A or B happening is 7 /
10 if you look at this set carefully you
will see that it contains numbers only
belonging to a only belonging to B and
belonging to both A and
B since this was a small set of numbers
we could use this method of looking for
numbers manually but for a bigger set we
may have to use a formula in the coming
video we will see how formula can be
used to find such
[Music]
probabilities